Today, you've got to look at what you're doing and ask yourself three key questions.
Can someone overseas do it cheaper?
Can a computer do it faster?
And does what you offer satisfy the growing nonmaterial, aesthetic, emotional,...
...even spiritual demands of a very abundant age?
You have to do something that's hard to outsource,...
...hard to automate and it serves a need that goes beyond functional.
And the abilities that meet this test...
...tend not to be those left-brained, linear, SAT spreadsheet abilities...
...although they still matter.
Instead, they tend to be the right-brained, artistic, empathic, big picture skills...
...we've often overlooked and undervalued.
Beyond that, two other things matter: intrinsic motivation and persistence.
You should do whatever you find inherently compelling, satisfying and challenging...
...rather than try to pursue external rewards such as higher pay or promotions.
The dirty little secret is that people who are intrinsically motivated,...
...who do what they do out of the joy and challenge of the task itself,...
...almost always outperform their extrinsically motivated peers.
The other quality is persistence.
I've seen this over and over.
The people who accomplish the most stick with it.
They persist, so should you.